chelsey starts off this hour in Virginia
hi Chelsea how are you I'm good how are
you doing better than I deserve what's
up Big Dave I was just calling to see so
I've had a whole life policy in place
for about six years now I'm sure I know
you are I know I know you're against
them so my question is should I close it
down I do have term as well should I
close it out and take the cash and put
towards debt or should I keep it open
since I've already paid all my premium
no you close it and get out and because
it's not going anywhere good from here
as soon as you've got the proper amount
of term insurance in place how much life
insurance do you need um my term is
around 1.7 million okay and what do you
make a year um me and my husband
combined around 300
what do you mean the on you is 1.7 yes
the term on me is 1.7 and I make around
200 okay all right so you've got a
little less than ten times your income
but that'll probably take care of
everybody if something happened to you
in your case because you've got an
unusually high income wonderful for you
okay and yeah you've got enough term
insurance in place and you know if you
don't need to do anything different than
yes I would not keep whole life life
insurance it's a bad place to park money
when you die the cash value goes to them
they only send you the face value and
you have paid for both you paid for the
cash who paid extra to build up the cash
value a lot extra and it grows at almost
nothing you know one to two percent
somewhere in their growth rate and you
know you you overpaid for the life
insurance you got a bad savings program
and they bundled them together and
that's all this is yeah that's how I was
sold about it yeah exactly
yeah I'm sorry so yeah you just you move
on you do your investing in good
investments never in life insurance and
you always buy the less expensive term
life insurance hey thanks for the call
so folks term insurance is about five
dollars for the same that you pay $100 a
month for the whole life so it's about
one-twentieth so five dollars the other
ninety five dollars out of your hundred
dollars going into a whole life policy a
month is going into this savings program
and if you notice the savings program on
our traditional whole life policy when
you look at the policy the first three
years your cash value is zero so you're
paying an extra ninety five dollars a
month for a savings account and for the
first three years they keep 100 percent
of the money that's called high fees
that's called you're getting screwed
high fees these aren't just inconvenient
high fees it's not the difference in a
four percent student loan and a six
percent student loan no this is they
kept all the money you put into the
investment for three years
this is stupid and then once you do
finally start building up some money it
accrues between one point two and two
percent and then once you do build up
some money after you got past the three
years of nothing the Land of Nod and you
got the land of not and then you got
finally a little bit of build up and
it's making a hole one percent and then
you die the ninety five dollars a month
out of every one hundred dollars paid
that you've been paying to build up
savings goes not to your family but to
the insurance company so you have a
savings account for the first three
years to keep all your money after that
they don't pay you much and when you die
they keep your money who would use this
bank most people in middle-class America
that's who because your life insurance
salesman sold you this crap it is the
payday lender of the middle-class most
middle-class and upper-class people
don't fall for the payday lender because
they go oh no that's a ripoff but then
they wander in and do whole life life
insurance and leash their cars which is
just right there with payday lending
mathematically it's just a different
tool to get
at the middle class and so but walking
around acting like you did something I
did it I bought that crap I'm sure and I
was straight out of college and some guy
that she knew from a fraternity where
she used to date some of the guy that
should have been my should have been my
hint right there but no I'll let this go
burr into my house and of course he's
all preppy and he's got his little
button-down going and he's brand-new in
the insurance business but he had the
pitch down and I bought it I've got a
degree in finance and I bought this crap
shop dumb I was so if you did it to
don't feel dumb just get out of it get
out of it as quick as you can
everybody does stupid stuff the trick is
to not do the same stupid stuff twice
that's the trick because there's plenty
of new stupid stuff to do without doing
the same ones over so just figure it out
I mean you figure out buying a new car
when you're a broke person new car goes
down and value like a rock that is
stupid so don't buy more new cars until
you're not a broke person anymore so
you've got a million dollar net worth
quit buying new cars over and over and
over again and somehow rationalizing and
justifying and telling mythology and
legendary tales about how used cars
break down and they're not reliable that
one's always cracked me up because you
know what a new car is after you've had
it a year it's a used car did it
suddenly become unreliable after you've
had it two years no so that's complete
rationalization BS that we tell
ourselves and then we go by the largest
thing that most people buy that goes
down in value a car I like cars but you
have to stop and think about these
things
stuff like whole life life insurance and
fleecing your car and financing a car
and buying new cars and you know just
start looking around and going I don't
think I really want to do rent owned
because I think by the time I've had
that washer and dryer for six months I
could have bought three sets well what I
gave those groups just do the math on
the thing man it's hundreds of percent
I'll interest and that's why rent owns
and the poor into town rich people don't
fall for that stuff that's
how they got rich think about it
no lotto tickets hardly are sold in the
rich into town that's I don't need it no
no you don't miss a point if rich people
knew that the lotto work they would hire
people to stand in line to buy the
tickets they know it doesn't work they
know you're more likely to be struck by
lightning three times on the way to the
market one mile from your home
statistically you have a higher
probability of being hit by lightning
three times while driving one mile to
the market then you do buying the
winning lotto ticket rich people can do
math that's one of the things that
helped them oh and by the way most of
them didn't start out rich 79 percent of
millionaires inherited zero start out
like I did nothing nothing and stupid
and the less stupid I got the more money
I got why is this a formula because it's
how life works we have to work our way
through these things together and that's
why you're listening and that's why I'm
here to help you